bientôt c'est ce que vit aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur squeeze le jeu vidéo un
certain petit bo a fait un jeu sur nous
elle a donc passé à toi tu pouvais jouer
tout de suite apparemment ça a l'air
d'être un jour agents au kenya elle
s'est pris un bien vite chez moi il faut
que je monte un truc c'est urgent ok
j'arrive
voilà le scénario affamés n'importe quel
scénario me fera plaisir thibault
retrouve cyprien chez lui alors petite
mise en page des contrôles auxquels
peuvent lui saute effet à gauche droite
c'est parfait on les a à la pelle sans
doute est un des morts lol c'est génial
[ __ ] tac aller ok on va tenter
n'importe quelle cellule rap hutin a
tenté par o o play holyfield les gens
très mignon qu'on fait un jeu pour le
moins c'est vraiment adorable a jamais
réussi
tak tak a sauté lie 1,3 entre les deux
pics et qu'il faut sauter là où je le
sais bordel hop là [ __ ] jamais réussi
là ok
et du coup on peut sauter pour esquiver
sa sortie mdr on avait pu voir vois ma
[ __ ] de tête la modifier à chaque fois
à chaque mort c'est très peu rassurant
mais elle à la fin d'un oui oui sortie
mdr je n'ai pas du tout confiance
on va aller là-bas non t'es sérieux
j'ai toujours détesté les pitbulls à
terre dans la vie je veux pas faire un
barbecue
je veux jamais mangé d'olive à l'apéro
puisque les peurs des pics donc qui dit
picdi cure dent donc la sortie c'est
vraiment là oh là là mais quelle
fourberie d'avocats chez moi qui ai une
barque comme ça je suis pas en confiance
ça veut dire que derrière il ya un truc
chelou y victor ivanov option mots
justice a pas du tout à gagner était
trop fort espace pour passer au niveau
suivant moi la fois cas où sa part dans
la ville au plus tard sa part dans le
vide déjà atteint un an j'étais sûr mais
c'est la fin ça veut dire quoi ce
panneau mario interdite sauter un
célibataire du grand écart dans le doute
j'ai fait ce qui me dit voilà donc le
mec là te dire dit de sauter plus bas et
un panneau où tu as le droit mais va
chier au hockey avec plateforme
invisible hélas hélas non non
hop le petit saut le petit truc
invisible le deuxième non mais non o o
holla holla l'ag
aller trop vite donc si je vais là il ya
des pics et ensuite à deux fois les
directs non la plateforme help elle
bouge
vous en faites pas [ __ ] vous en faites
bonjour je suis jeune j'ai trouvé la
solution il suffit d'attendre de tomber
à plus tard bonjour je suis valentin et
j'ai trouvé la solution il suffit de
gérer gros beauf
voilà le chemin de la victoire alors
châtelet les halles c'est quoi ça c'est
l'application de bol c'est le logo non
l'application bardot mais du coup oh oh
oh oui ok sur le métro
adacore le logo l'implication de tim but
quoi parfait un peu de respect pour ton
créateur un ouvrage esquive le l'autre
on est d'empêcher les hippies dessus hop
là haut elle est pas seule elle a appelé
l'application squeeze sur ipad aux plats
aux lyonnaises se rallier au lait biache
haut c'est trop dur mais à temps mais je
le fête annoncée du vide de près de
paris iii paris iii pas les trois là je
sens ça monte ça monte c'est comme dans
une pique en bois rial au début et d'un
couapel en ébullition tac
non je quitte pas ses juges je fais mais
voit les vocalises à à sa photo ma barbe
voilà baby à l'actif ce [ __ ] de jeu
dans curiaces à l'acquis de way you move
on the train le trajet perdent à aa
j'en peux plus j'aimerais un jour sortir
de la guerre chaque télé à 15 soit
desserré autour de cette sas est une
tradition de journalistes montant des
attendez attendez j'ai trouvé le truc
mon gars il suffit juste d'attendre et
normand ils vont tous passé un pareil si
j'ai un à [ __ ] voilà donc pas du tout
il a prévu le coup leur foire et il est
malin et voici maintenant moi j'arrive
tout la raquette de celle là l'est elle
arrive pas passer les ou non plus [ __ ]
on n'est jamais allé aussi loin
il y avait des six à ce quizz idée ce
quia mois des squeeze moi on va déjeuner
c'est un piège à je pète un câble tnt un
menteur tu es un menteur tu es un
menteur tu es un menteur il aurait pas
osé mon gars il ose la fils de chien
mais les deux chiens et hubris dévier
des 15 danse à bloquer niveau suivant on
s'en fout on est passé c'est l'important
et salut toi au revoir oh la la
olalala deux belles ok on est bon au
matin au niveau de deux pics qui est
quand même au piquant excellent
combattant pour la petit tampon qui fait
plaisir aux tempes aux tempes autant
tous et robes jaunes et 5 rouges bordel
je compulse de rage lac ont vu leur âge
nouvelle maladie décrété par les fils
des années non mais en fait faut juste
que je me barre vite perdre et on
m'appelle le ninja m'appelle l'éclair au
chocolat
rexel au total louis testud dit saef des
pays avec des pics à l'est ah ok on y
est pop
allez mes jambes me cyprien j'arrive
cyprien je sais pas pourquoi aux opus il
dit
là il ya des pics qui vont arriver faut
juste sauté à un avion peut aller sur sa
non ya pas un truc où se poser là haut
si regardez je savais que ça finirait
comme ça c'est quoi ça avoir un truc où
se cacher là j'arrive cyprien au nom
dans un moteur on ira chez toi là
cyprien tu attends c'est vrai on va
enfin savoir ce qu'il est urgent de dire
bordel de merde et ce qui est d'accord
pour que ces prêts à aimer il soit enfin
officiellement renommé en squeeze gamme
et alors on passe comment cette merde
allez et manon salesse effrayant que se
passe-t-il cyprien
non rien ouais ouattara et voilà nous
apporte cette vidéo sur ce fan game
[ __ ] c'était génial quand même jade
[ __ ] c'est incroyable c'est la
première fois que quelqu'un fait ça et
ça me savait mieux je suis tout ému
merci beaucoup thibault n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo ça vous a plu comme
d'habitude et si vous aussi vous voulez
faire pourquoi pas un petit joue comme
ça sur rail comme thème la chaîne
youtube ou alors un animé une chanson à
fanar bref j'en sais rien n'hésitez pas
à en faire un et à me l'envoyer s'offre
un grand plaisir le plus parfois je les
relayent pour vous remercier en fait
même savoir regarder une chaîne tout le
monde dit ça je crois que des pompes
[Musique]
vasic
oh